again july but in quarantine years it
felt like you got to quit these corn ten
years you've been with us since
july yeah chabot how long you been with
your girl uh
two plus yeah strong
strong yeah and honestly i admired that
i admire
everyone and if i have to invest in
relations if you if two of you
if your relationships are stocked yeah
i'm buying chappelle stock
what about mine so he should ask
chappelle wait wait what mine is
listen you might just you know mine is
thriving though if we want to up you
invest in it when it's new it's easy
again quarantine's been tough on a lot
of relationships
like it's been time we we together we
spend a lot of time together
like a lot of time so i get happy when
i'm on the road i'm like i get to see
the fellas but we get we spend a lot of
time because it's new
so you know so you pick you you learn
stuff faster that you wouldn't normally
do in quarantine because it's
everything is closed so what do we do we
go to each other house right
and we learn little stuff that bothered
me i would have not known
in like let's say two years down the
line like a little she has hair probably
are you saying you would have found out
i would have found it i'm sorry
she has hair all over the place i'm like
from her hair yeah from her hair she's
she's losing hair no no she's just like
having long hair and it's like
all over the place it's girls yeah yeah
exactly but i was like but
listen i go to her house it's you know
on the rug it's hair i'm like yo
i again i appreciate the long hair i
love looking at your long hair
i just like looking at it on you not on
the floor but she can't help it for her
no no no again she's going no she's not
going bald brendan but when she comes
over
those girls hairs just do that like it
just yeah yeah yeah
but when she looks but it's so much hair
but like my hair is longer too
i found a hair today i'm like god damn
like every time you comb it out yeah it
comes out it's just here
yeah but it's all over the carpet yeah
all over but that does she not clean it
no no because she's she clean listen
here right
because my girl's here comes out raining
all over the run right
chappelle's girl's hair comes out in all
over the rug it's all over me
i can still wear black it's not all over
my [ __ ] pants
again i just said hair that bugs me and
again well that means all girls would
bug you yeah no no
no [ __ ] up right
again brenda brendan
i'm saying yo you know what i mean
listen i don't all girls here comes out
unless
it's a blackberry your hair's not your
hair your hair's not all over the place
is it it can if you don't vacuum that's
the only thing you're not cleaning up
after yourself
that's what i'm saying here she's messy
she's not messy it's clean she's ocd
it's not clean though if there's hair
all the way there's a rug oh there's
some [ __ ] going on there
in the bathroom and it's wool
i'm trying to i'm trying to i'm trying
to defend all right hold on baby let's
talk about this
huh if there's hair all over that's
maybe maybe you should not clean it a
lot
let's talk about your relationship hold
on what no she's not dirty are you dirty
i know i'm ocd like honestly i must have
ocd if here bothers you
yeah but again i clean up after but i'm
saying
that nags me and we talked about it i
was like hey listen can you just be
conscious
and aware what can she do her [ __ ]
hair's falling that's what bro i'm not
i'm not
trying to change her i'm just saying
like just can't be honest that bothers
you
it just bothers you but what can she do
i guess vacuum more
yeah that's it that's it and i honestly
i take the integrity and i just like
the initiative i should say i take the
initiative to just like vacuum her place
i do stuff like that she comes up listen
we're great
brendan i'm the love doctor get on out
of here now i'm sorry do you all say the
l word
y'all say y'all love you no no you
haven't done that yet not yet
yeah well but what happened you guys in
quarantine
where you at now you like [ __ ]
no i mean i think it's more you see
yourself saying it yeah but i think it's
more for her
then then i think i slipped up and said
girl i love you
and then she came back she was in the
bathroom she was like she walked him out
you love me
what'd you say
yeah but i think it's more for her like
me saying it to her
what do you mean like like i said over
the new years like we hung uh like hey
you know you're gonna say it i'll say it
i know you're saying hey
come on man wait did she watch this are
you gonna spoil it for her
i'm not she don't watch it she gave up
does your girl watch the show no she'll
watch anything i do no yeah yeah
they shouldn't it's not like she this
how she and she gets mad at me like i'll
watch the news and try to like study and
research for like a current event and
all that instead of spending time with
her she's like oh you're on your podcast
[ __ ]
i was like okay just relax i'm still
trying to educate myself you mean just
that you're watching the news yeah
watching
cuz she knows the only reason why she
was like you doing this podcast
what else should you get upset about
that you do yeah
before when in the airbnb i heard you
arguing
are you oh yeah what's your job what
city what city
i mean name a city i know right we've
been to a lot of them
but now wait wait wait i've heard jar
you before with her yeah
she's tripping blah blah blah oh well
that's a little because
again that's not an argument that's me
expressing what i can't say
i'm like man this girl is tripping yeah
right because
she's not getting it so i i need her she
needs a moment then she
doesn't get it like just a little stuff
like okay the podcast situation right
when i did the whole dish on lil shawn
and stuff like that clearly it's for
entertainment it's this whole persona
rollerboard yeah she thought it was deep
because
she was like oh you still caught up on
your ex i said whoa let's not let's not
do it yeah yeah let's not do that
because yeah everyone
girl but but she did sometimes it just
takes her
a while to process that so that's why i
was like bro if you're gonna do this
sweetie
don't watch it at all so she is instead
of like to avoid the argument
she won't watch it at all yeah have you
have you and stevie every guy on
argument over
anything on shows uh no not on shows
usually
i fought with him a lot when we first
started dating oh about what
because i used to think he was so
sketchy based off the way you guys talk
to each other like i wanted yeah i
wanted nothing to do with stevie when i
first met him
yeah yeah i mean yeah he did seven years
of hard time yeah yeah
i wanted nothing to do with him and he
kept hitting on me and i was like okay
maybe i'll like get to know this guy and
i used to fight with him all the time
random [ __ ] cuz i thought he was sketchy
as [ __ ] i thought he was out here
like on some [ __ ] [ __ ] i thought he was
a [ __ ] boy no
yeah and then like i got to know him
like oh like you work out all day and go
to like home depot to do diy projects
at home yeah that's all he does i don't
really help you
fight with him especially nothing over
the show nothing right
no i think it's just one of those things
like i don't think i would have believed
anybody unless i saw it myself because
you guys are all boys
that's true that is that is very scary
yes
actually i would have listened to
brendan though brendan always has like
my best interest oh yeah he always gives
me a heads up
yeah yo listen he talks all the time is
my older brother
i want to go back to your girl losing
her hair
he's trying to get down to something
what are you trying to get at again my
girl
wheels on facetime worried about her
hairs all over the place okay
that's the things that nag me again
we're in great space literally
i facetimed what else but what else that
but i mean the hairs whatever she could
she can't control it what else
um not too much i mean she called me her
little jaguar i was like yeah cause
you're a jackpot
yeah you ever seen like a jaguar run
she called you that's her the pet name
for you jaguar jaguar
it's french jaguar
yeah jaguar yeah yeah why are you making
what would nags heard about you uh i
think that i'm
constantly on my phone remember that
thanksgiving that thanksgiving yeah
i'm with her you know what's funny is
you text the group chat you went
dude my girl tripping because i'm on my
phone and all of a sudden
dude yeah i remember that
you're on your phone a lot yeah well
again even around us you're on your
phone a lot
i'm the love group i'm the love doctor i
mean he's out there
i'm helping people you scroll on the
ground
yeah but and what happened when remember
when we looked on the phone and says
what you're looking at yeah
remember when we did that we did that
and my social media was through to the
right
it was it was like the social media bar
was like so if you have an iphone oh
like yeah
iphone sunday weekly relativity yeah
yeah your weekly activity and mom was
through the roof but uh
nah that's the only thing like being on
my phone but i'm always present
she tells me story and here's the thing
let's listen to her stories now
women tell stories and we can all be
honest stupid stories okay i didn't want
to say that thank you
just a comment stupid story for you
that's a little different oh she's a
homie yeah but i'm saying your girl
and she is a businesswoman like she
works she's a producer
right and she like gets like and she's
in the entertainment field so i got to
hear about people i don't care about
but i'm i'm involved and i give her i
give her advice she says that patrice
o'neill has the best joke about that by
the way about what
uh somebody got shot yeah yeah who got
shot
yeah yeah dude because she was trying to
tell them a story about gun or someone
got shot
but she never said it no yeah she would
just go off about like you know me my
friend we don't like guns we just think
they can
take good shots did she get shot no
she gets shot and why are you telling me
did she shoot somebody
no yeah why are you cuz she don't like
guns oh it's one of the
yeah greatest [ __ ] and i can relate
like but again
but it goes to your advice now three
years down the line she tells me that
same story
i'm be tuning her out but right now it's
fresh i'm listening
with it you're putting over the story
but but again
like i'm invested and we're great so
yeah i'm present all the time she's just
like yo you on your phone a lot
jim what bothers you about your girl
here she's trying to hit her i'm just
trying to figure out are you the love
doctor
nothing no nothing when someone says
listen
no she doesn't listen to anything i do
at all the only time
she should do it the only time she even
knew something was that freaking king of
the sting thing with a date
and that was that was she mad at carl
she got hurt
yeah why oh because you were together
and went on that date and i was you know
i was
going around you were with your
girlfriend and you drank all that sake
and i was playing around with a big tip
exactly
well you know this is going to happen
i'm going to make it like as fun as
possible
energy was upset entertainment that's
kind of yeah that's validated yeah
i couldn't help that but there's nothing
that that she does that just pissed you
off
i think i told you guys at in nashville
didn't i
no yeah oh he was in an african-american
did she play a bunch of activities
like uh didn't you go through
the cupcakes as well you made uh
old-fashioned yeah i mean that didn't
bother me
it's just i don't know what i'm
definitely going to say
i don't know i know she doesn't watch it
but i'm for whatever reason whenever i
talked about someone before like someone
knew someone that knew someone that knew
someone and then they found out
yeah mm-hmm oh we gotta edit this
what do you think uh bothers her about
you
um well you know i drink every day
that bothers her you don't get i've
never seen you i don't get drunk but
then
of course you know now that she's around
me more often it does feel like
do you have to drink today and i'm like
yeah my girl does oh yeah but i want to
relax
hates my drinking hates it so that's one
thing yeah
you're getting another you only you you
only do it at night when it's like
winding down right
every night for the most part at night
time but then we've done it here
like i'll do it i'll do it here every
now and then like if i don't pick up my
son from school i drink
or at night i usually have a drink i'm
taking january
off yeah wow until san marcos
but i don't think that's stellar but
that's the end of january oh but
i mean that's really but i mean
everything that she didn't relax yeah
everything that she doesn't
agree with what with me i think it's
valid the drinking
she'll just worry about your healthier
yeah yeah but i'm like yeah otherwise
i'm i treat you you are a pretty healthy
guy
yeah overall i would say sardines all
right sardines they're right there
yeah what does your girl you i mean you
guys are pretty solid anyway
you don't do i mean what do you do
like what would you do that piss her off
i don't know i don't do anything i know
you just kind of chill yeah
i mean the only thing uh i think at
first like she was just asking a lot
about
because i have a lot of uh friends that
are girls from cheerleaders
so she would ask about them a lot but
i'm like if you understand they're
smoking
yeah they're really hot she's like she's
like why are all of them hot yeah i go
there i don't [ __ ] know
you know i mean that's just how they are
but like i'm like you have the hottest
friends in the world
i know i do and they come to the shows
i'm like jesus
that's your friend i hope that's not
like and now he's like hey
this guy bought two shirts dude wanted
to meet you
get out of here i bet i apologize he's
gonna fly to palm beach man
i didn't do that i followed you these
guys man i'm checking can you sign his
shirts
yeah i did i'll never forget
this guy wants you to sign a hood what
are you doing dude
that would be tough for your girl yeah
that was yeah which initially yeah of
course but like
i was like would you be cool with her if
she had a bunch of hot guy friends
i mean yeah go for it really yeah like i
mean because i mean
the thing is it's like what they're
gonna cheat they're gonna cheat it would
already happen
yeah you know i've known these i've
known them for years like since we were
like 15 years old
so it's it's a different case and like
when she meets them i'm like you just
got to meet him and when she meets them
she's totally fine she's like oh okay
she's like
she she because you you would see the
vibe if it was there
sure it would have dude it would have
already happened yeah
you know that's good but but i i respect
that you know
she did bring it to my attention i
respect that she actually told me
instead of just like being quiet about
it yeah and just being like
why you you know like just you know
being snarky about it and
but she communicated uh with me
on that and it's like oh okay like does
your name explain your girl come from a
good family
yeah decent family yeah yeah yeah
not like i mean yeah yes yes mom and dad
are together
no they're not they haven't been
together for like years or whatever but
not the same background as you
no no no
yeah [ __ ] no that'd be tough
i mean interesting i mean it is
interesting i mean like
what do you do yeah that's what [ __ ]
asking everybody got a truck at you what
do you do yeah
i do that it's my girl what are you
doing
uh uh jeez where do i start
starting off tough to deal with okay um
what do i do that pisses her off
nothing to me is a big deal nothing oh
got it so you're very nothing so my son
took on the same
kind of personality where he'll spill
something be like
it's not a big deal mom it's not a big
deal because to me nothing's a big deal
yeah i'll figure out whatever it is
drives are nuts i have a solution
so like whatever you name something
nothing like to me
nothing's a big deal yeah everything
i'll figure out and i'll get over it
yeah you're fine i don't stay mad
ever i'll be mad for two minutes and
then and i'm over it yeah she'll stay
mad
for three days i don't think i've ever
seen you like just like
piss i'll get heated and then i'll think
about it and then i'll get over well
like i mean like a consistent like
this yeah now she harps on the situation
and like
no she doesn't harp on it she just she
is tr she's
because i'll say uh it's not a big deal
and it's triggering for
oh got it yeah so it'll be like some
major [ __ ]
like her grandma passing away but it's
not a big deal i mean how old is she
and she'll be like she's like 90. i'm
like that's what 90 that's what 90 year
olds do
and she'll get super upset because she's
like oh you have no you know
you have no love for this or what i'm
like but it's like that's
life like that's the circle of life yeah
90 you're out man
you had a good run great run
90. you drew a [ __ ]
is good 90 years yeah great run 90 years
great run now now now you said 90. you
chose that number
we didn't ask it you gave it to us what
is there any significance behind the
number ninety
for you that means she's old that's
ninety yeah that was her [ __ ]
like my my grandma i think's 98.
oh damn congratulations she might be 99
not in shape none shaped swims every day
dance but like when she passes it's like
i wasn't that close to her but like my
dad would be like [ __ ] up about it but
like
what is your dad's mom yeah i probably
won't fly home to the
funeral like i missed my other grandma
who i was way closer with
i miss her funeral that's your mom's mom
yeah yeah like that stuff
that's that's not how that's life dude
damn
yeah i mean yeah that's yeah but other
than that
nothing bothers you other than that
nothing now now
that you're not you're not oh i'm messy
i'm real messy
but then this is uh you know what they
they surveyed like
g i'm not saying i'm a genius but this
is the excuse i give my girl
they surveyed geniuses from history like
the top smartest minds in the world
you know what they all had in common
they were messy unorganized
i'm messy yeah like i'll put my my shoes
everywhere my clothes everywhere my
drives my girl nuts
damn she has ocd she has a bad ocd
yeah like if i put like i'll use almond
milk for something and i'll put it
in the wrong spot she'll freak out oh
really i don't give a [ __ ]
dude drives her crazy yeah that probably
that'd probably drive me again
yeah i put that right there uh
oh i'm not like with our kid she's super
disciplined i'm not
too cool dad i'm the fun dad damn
bad cop good cop mm-hmm
but also i'm like he'll make a mistake
and she'll get real mad
and then uh he'll be like hey i'm gonna
write uh mama like a note saying
sorry i'm like yeah do that so i'll help
him like draw whatever oh okay yeah and
then he'll give it to her
and she still won't she'll still hold
the grudge oh she she gets mad and i'll
look at her like
you're [ __ ] up pondering on that
situation yeah okay
okay so two bet you can't have two bad
cops no good cop what else you got
well yeah look at this i'm a pretty
cool dude okay cool dude that's
imperative sentence
he's in the class right now so you know
so it's three things so you know
we're like should be real stressed and i
think she'll be mad that i'm not more
stressed like could it be
chaos at home with you guys yeah i'm
pretty i'm like
yeah she's like can you want another one
like i want two more see how the [ __ ]
i'm like we'll figure it out figure it
out i was just worried about it over
here don't figure it out
there's people with way less who figure
it out yeah true yeah
so it's not a set plan it's just like go
with the flow we'll figure it out we'll
figure it out okay
are you trying to be love doctor to this
dude no no i'm just i'm just grasping
i'm just
understanding the situation now now you
said you said you said she's ocd and
you're a little messy now how long ago
i'm definitely messy how long have you
been messy my entire life entire life
now do you making a habit that like okay
my wife
no i don't care and that's oh now so it
goes back to the nonchalance
okay now how does she feel about that
how i'm nonchalant right yeah
oh drive's a nuts you know that no
you have the floor okay because these
questions are in toronto all right
so listen is that a is
all right what country is that yeah you
want to go where
you want to go
[Laughter]
hello all right all right well there's
this oh so so so so so you're saying
here
is you're you're nonchalantness
and she has ocd and you say you don't
care oh i'm also super protective of my
son
so she comes from the like her mom used
to spank her stuff
and like hit her yeah and she can't hit
tiger around me
yeah that won't happen yeah and that's
fair that's fair it won't happen that's
fair
okay okay so she's strict on discipline
i like that i like that
now now here's the thing do you
again agree you're a great dad great
husband but i'm i'm trying to dig deep a
little bit
go ahead man all right you said careful
what you find daddy
i'm very careful you know i won't i
won't waste a drop let me just tell you
something
so
that would sound way ugh sexual
let me write that down you scoring goals
let me write today let me write that
down i won't waste a drop
no no no yeah you ocd i mean you're
messing your girl have the worst sexy
talk of all time
is bad you're a new orleans fan
you think the saints are going to win
this division that is good to keep going
we this is new for us like we
you know we're not not trying to find
out about each other yeah exactly keep
going
but let's go back to you yeah yeah
she's like we're running out of room i'm
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
oh
i like that she's ocd and your shoes all
over the place and you're running out of
water well they're they're not that
they're all
all over the place but when i get a new
pair of shoes just say are you gonna
throw something out like
no why would i throw him out no i
collect shoes
is she claustrophobic nope okay okay
okay any phobias she has where is he
getting it nope
no no phobias any phobias do you have
you're a terrible doctor
right no no this is this you got to die
no phobias no phobias okay
so so so so you're messy you have shoes
everywhere she's ocd she cleans up
and y'all mesh your kids she's you're
not you're the cool dad she's very
protective
mom's strict she liked to whoop her kids
because i mean she's never whooped up
she never whipped them
exactly special friend you don't
tolerate that okay then you said then
you also
you said um tiger right this is um
correct me if i'm wrong you said uh when
you named write letters she ponder on
situations too long she harps on stuff
too long
right now does that annoy you uh yes
it does okay now how do you express that
with her
i mean we just talked about dude what do
you say i'm just if i'm your wifey
you're brilliant i'm miss brendan's shop
go ahead over
what dude this is terrible over what
what do you mean i
i don't like it brandon i don't like it
i just i tell her she just needs to get
over it but
i wouldn't i won't entertain it i don't
stay mad so she can stay mad i keep
going
so she's fuming yeah just i keep my
power through like everything's all good
and she has no choice but to adapt to it
because the kids you know they'll pick
up on it
okay that's it
but i think your biggest problem today
i'm messy and and i do
and i drink a lot remember when she met
when i know about her sober i didn't
drink at all
so when like at night she would like
another drink because there's alcohol
uh issues in my family so she's worried
about that
oh god but she she what i'm what i'm
gaining from this situation she's
she know how to adapt when y'all met you
i know how to adapt well yeah of course
well
because you're fighting background and
all that but also you just give credit
to your queen
because she knows that dap as well for
sure you know
when she met me we had a 300 square foot
apartment oh damn we're sleeping on the
floor oh yeah that's right and i only
had an ipad
yeah that's how y'all watch tv yeah we
watch the same movie
over and over there that's some creed
[ __ ] that's when he was
moved to philly he had to watch like
damn you know any other movies
but yeah ace ventura some about mary oh
[ __ ]
happy gilmore yeah that's a good movie
selection that's a great movie
all right well good work man oh thank
you
was this the love episode i don't know i
gotta love it how about
when i get